although this time of year we're all
focused on family it's hard to keep the
holiday spirit up when there isn't much
family around I spoke with 76 year old
Sheila Zakia who says it's the time of
year she dreads but she didn't always
feel this way
just the noise would be at another level
that would be a typical Christmas
gathering for Sheila Zakia with her late
husband Louie's family and sometimes the
crowd would get lucky and get to hear
Louis play his accordion he would say oh
I can't play that and then all of a
sudden there it goes to now being able
to hear a pin drop pretty lonely from
having a giant Christmas tree to a small
one I guess our gift list was like 50
people it's Zaki as a new normal for the
holidays after Louis passed away in
2018. when you're a senior you still
have a lot of life to give
but you like The Elf on the Shelf
um
they know you're there but they just
don't
pick up the phone and give you a call
Zaki as one of thousands of seniors
alone during the holidays an AARP study
showed 28 percent of U.S adults over the
age of 50 are lonely during this time
you do tend to throw a lot of pity
parties which is not good for um
depression she's right studies show that
feeling lonely or being isolated is as
dangerous to your body as smoking 15
cigarettes a day but help is out there
the Jewish Family Service Agency has a
senior companionship program for anyone
in the valley when we're a senior
volunteer goes out and becomes a friend
to one of our more isolated seniors in
the community because sometimes having a
friend could go a long way and I'm sure
that if there was a lady you would like
to go to lunch with me I'd give her a
call on a flat minute
now through all of this Zacchaeus still
showed gratitude for what she does have
if you are a senior who needs a friend
we will have resources up on our website
at 8 newsnow.com back to you